[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visa-politik zuschauer man sagt
dass die leidenschaft der spanier der
fußball sei aber was sie noch besser
können ist sich selbst ein bein zu
stellen und jedes mal wenn wir hier auch
das war politik über spanien gesprochen
haben war der häufigste kommentar dass
sie sehr pessimistisch sind und das
selbstvertrauen an ihre nation verloren
haben obwohl sie in der rangliste
weltweit größten wirtschaftsmächte noch
immer an vierzehnter stelle stehen mit
anderen worten es scheint so als die
ihre pessimismus ihr nationalsport
ebenso wie fußball schauen und ehrlich
gesagt haben sie viele gründe
pessimistisch zu sein es gibt einen
haufen probleme und bedrohungen denen
sie sich täglich stellen müssen
abgesehen davon gibt es aber auch eine
andere seite und ich denke das es wert
ist die zu erwähnen in den letzten vier
jahrzehnten hat die spanische
gesellschaft und ihre wirtschaft einen
riesigen sprung vollführt
seit dem einzug der demokratie in
spanien am ende der 19 siebziger jahre
hat sich sehr viel verändert das land
hat sich modernisiert und mit voller
geschwindigkeit in die weltwirtschaft
integriert in diesem zeitraum es zum
beispiel die beschäftigungsquote um 15
punkte gestiegen was millionen und
abermillionen neue arbeitsplätze
geschaffen hat die ausländischen
direktinvestitionen haben sich im
verhältnis zum bruttoinlandsprodukt um
sage und schreibe das 27-fache
vervielfacht angefangen haben sie mit
weniger als zwei prozent des bip und
sind dann auf fast 54 prozent gestiegen
auch auf der anderen seite ist spanien
seinerseits zu einem der größten
investoren im ausland aufgestiegen seit
jahren investieren spanische unternehmen
zweistellige milliardenbeträge in der
ganzen welt besonders natürlich in
lateinamerika
und das ist noch nicht alles die spanier
haben es doch tatsächlich geschafft dank
ihrer offenheit beim handel das
gleichgewicht der exporte und importe im
einklang zum bip auf ein rekordniveau zu
steigern und dabei das verhältnis von
beschäftigung und kapital zu verdoppeln
spanien nach einer der zehn besten
infrastrukturen der welt aufgebaut ob an
land in der luft oder zu wasser durch
zugverbindungen flug oder schiffshäfen
mit anderen worten spanien ist
heutzutage ein relativ reiches und
entwickeltes land das sich kraftvoll in
die weltweite wirtschaftliche
entwicklung integriert hat aus all den
wir wollen nicht nur über die wirtschaft
reden
[Musik]
in den letzten jahrzehnten hat sich auch
die ausbildung der spanier verbessert
sowohl in quantitativer als auch
qualitativer hinsicht es mag
überraschend klingen aber laut oecd
daten ist die grundkompetenz der
spanische schüler in lesen und
mathematik 89 stärker gestiegen als in
jedem anderen europäischen land
abgesehen von finnland
außerdem und ich denke dass dies im
kontext dieses videos besonders
interessant ist die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung ist momentan die
dritthöchste der welt nach japan und der
schweiz aber halt das ist so ziemlich
das ende dieser geschichte
[Musik]
schließlich soll dieses video ja keine
werbung dafür sein wie toll spanien ist
nein wir wollen die wichtigsten
turbulenzen untersuchen welche die
zukunft des landes bedrohen denn die
bedrohungen und herausforderungen sind
so gewaltig dass spanien so schnell wie
möglich handeln muss wenn es nicht einen
wirtschaftlichen tsunami erleiden will
liebe visual politik fans was ihr euch
heute vorstellen sind die größten
bedrohungen für spanien und damit auch
für die wirtschaft und die stabilität
der europäischen union selbst und wisst
ihr was all diese bedrohungen gehen
zurück auf einen gemeinsamen nenner
die last des alters
ob es nun an der verbesserten
gesundheitsversorgung der mediterranen
ernährung den guten bier oder den tapas
liegt die die spanier so sehr lieben
fakt ist dass spanien das land mit der
dritthöchsten durchschnittlichen die
erwartung der welt ist und was auf der
einen seite ein segen ist kann auf der
anderen seite zu einer großen belastung
werden vor allem wenn man die
zweitniedrigste geburtenrate aller
entwickelten länder hat
demographische katastrophe die pandemie
das problem in spanien verschärft einen
bevölkerung in der es immer weniger
geburten gibt ja eine höhere
lebenserwartung und weniger kinder das
ergebnis ist eine zunehmend alternde
bevölkerung mit ausnahme einiger
kleinstaaten gehört spanien bereits zu
den zehn ländern mit dem höchsten
durchschnittsalter wir sprechen hier von
knapp über 43 jahren anders gesagt in
spanien kommen auf 100 kinder unter 16
jahren 125 erwachsene über 64 jahren
aber all das ist nicht die einzige
katastrophe das schlimmste ist dass ich
in den nächsten jahrzehnten die alterung
der spanischen gesellschaft noch
beschleunigen wird
das bedeutet wenn ende der 1990 er jahre
die bevölkerung im alter von 65 jahren
oder älter einen anteil von 13 prozent
an der gesamtbevölkerung ausmacht sind
es heute fast 20 prozent und im jahr
2050 wird jeder dritte spanier diese
altersgruppe angehören bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt tatsächlich zahl der
arbeitenden bevölkerung sehr
wahrscheinlich fast 4 millionen
verringern sodass in spanien auf jeden
über 65 jährigen nur noch 1,6 menschen
im erwerbsfähigen alter kommen wenn hier
keine maßnahmen ergriffen werden könnte
dass das wachstum und damit die
wirtschaftlichen perspektiven des landes
mehr als erheblich beeinträchtigen und
das nur unter der voraussetzung dass die
lebenserwartung dank neuer medizinischer
und technologischer fortschritte nicht
noch schneller steigt als erwartet denn
sollte dies der fall sein dann werden
die zahlen noch sehr viel schlechter
ausfallen aber aufgepasst wenn der
potenzielle verlust von arbeitskräften
ist zwar erheblich aber bei weitem nicht
das größte problem
[Musik]
dies ist nicht nur irgendein
herausforderung dies ist ein mega
tsunami in spanien nächsten jahrzehnten
erwarten kann und wie wir bereits
erwähnt haben früher oder später dort
ganz europa vom gleichen problem
betroffen sein wir sprechen über renten
gesundheits und pflegeleistungen der
rechnungshof bescheinigt der
sozialversicherung ein neues rekord
fixiert
53,16 milliarden euro die staatsausgaben
erreichen rekordhöhen nachdem sie das
defizit der sozialversicherung
übernommen haben die autonomen regionen
werden bis 2030 35 milliarden euro
zusätzlich für sozialausgaben benötigen
und achtung zu sprechen hier nicht über
irgendwelche kinkerlitzchen bedenkt
bitte der spanier in einigen jahren
einerseits viel weniger bürger im
erwerbsfähigen alter haben wird und
andererseits millionen abermillionen
neuer rentner die viele öffentliche
dienste und leistungen in anspruch
nehmen werden wie um alles in der welt
sollen all diese rechnungen bezahlt
werden wer wird sie bezahlen wird sie
überhaupt jemand bezahlen können und die
mit abstand wichtigste frage von allen
was kann man dagegen tun ist spanien
unwiederbringlich den untergang geweiht
aufgepasst
[Musik]
eine ecke weiter anschwellende rechnung
was passiert im allgemeinen wenn man 65
oder 67 jahre alt wird nun die meisten
gehen in den ruhestand das heißt diese
personen hören auf zu arbeiten und leben
von ihrer rente in spanien ist das ein
system wie in vielen anderen ländern ein
öffentliches und umlagefinanzierten
systemen das heißt die arbeitnehmer von
heute zahlen mit ihren beiträgen für die
renten von heute aber das geld der
renten beitragszahler reicht schon bei
weitem nicht der anteil der renten
zuschüsse aus dem staatshaushalt wächst
unaufhörlich so dass der steuerzahler im
wesentlichen zum zahler der renten wird
wir sprechen hier bereits von einem euro
aus der staatskasse im verhältnis zu
zweieinhalb euros aus der
rentenversicherung
und eine kurze randbemerkung seit dem
jahr 2000 sind die kosten für die renten
um 160 prozent gestiegen
zudem gelingt es der sozialversicherung
seit jahren nicht mehr ihren
finanzhaushalt auszugleichen seien
zwischen 2017 und 2020 betrug das
defizit mehr als 80 milliarden euro und
es wird erwartet dass allein dieses im
jahr 2029 über 40 milliarden euro
betragen wird wie gesagt die
herausforderungen die vor uns liegen
sind groß viel größer als erwartet
so wie es aussieht gehen die prognosen
davon aus dass die bevölkerung im
erwerbsfähigen alter bis 2050 um fast 4
millionen schrumpfen während die zahl
der menschen über 65 mindestens sechs
millionen steigen wird und diese werden
im schnitt immer höhere renten benötigen
wenn also die rechnung heutzutage schon
nicht mehr aufgeht was blüht dem land
dann in naher zukunft houston ich glaube
wir haben hier wirklich ein problem denn
das ist noch lange nicht das ende dieses
dramas
[Musik]
der bedarf ältere menschen erstreckt
sich nicht nur auf der renten sondern
auch auf das gesundheitswesen und die
ausgaben für pflegeleistungen in spanien
gibt es bereits ein riesiges netz von
heimen tageszentren und häuslichen
diensten mehr als eine million ältere
menschen betreuen und ihm ein würdiges
leben ermöglichen dennoch liegt der
prozentsatz älterer menschen mit
einflüssen der häuslichen pflege
diensten immer noch unter dem
europäischen standard was bedeutet dass
die öffentlichen ausgaben für die
altenpflege in spanien derzeit unter dem
eu durchschnitt liegen dann muss man nur
eins und eins zusammenzählen da ist
immer mehr ältere menschen gibt muss
spanien mehr ausgeben und wenn es die
nachfrage nach dienstleistungen dem
niveau anderer europäischer länder
annehmen wird bedeutet das dass sie dazu
gezwungen sind noch mehr auszugeben und
wenn nicht mehr meine sage ich viel mehr
sehr viel mehr und hinzu kommen noch die
kosten für das gesundheitswesen und sich
eine vorstellung darüber zu machen die
durchschnittlichen ausgaben pro kopf für
die altersgruppe der 65 bis 74 jährigen
liegen doppelt so hoch wie der
gesamtdurchschnitt und wenn wir über die
über 75 jährigen sprechen verdreifachen
sich die kosten sogar und daraus wird
sehr schnell ersichtlich wie sich die
gesundheitsausgaben in einem zunehmend
alternden land entwickeln werden
bretten pflege und gesundheitswesen
prognosen gehen davon aus dass
mindestens die belastung dieser drei
haushaltsposten bis 2050 und sieben bis
zwanzig prozentpunkte des bip steigen
wird und ihr wisst ja was mit
offiziellen prognosen zu öffentlichen
ausgaben oft passiert sie legen fast
immer daneben und fast nie darunter wir
sprechen hier über dutzende vielleicht
hunderte von milliarden an zusätzlichen
öffentlichen ausgaben in den folgenden
jahren und das alles in einer zeit in
der die bevölkerung im erwerbsfähigen
alter schrumpft
[Musik]
wird es jetzt also allmählich klar vor
welt ungeheure herausforderung spanien
ähnlich wie die meisten anderen
europäischen länder steht und an diesem
punkt müssen wir uns ganz klar die frage
stellen hat spanien bereits jeden punkt
überschritten an dem es kein zurück mehr
gibt den tatsächlichen point of no
return bedeutet dass alles was spanien
unwiderruflich zur krise und zum
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
zusammenbruch verdammt ist nun auch wenn
dies überraschend klingen mag nicht
unbedingt und nein dies ist keine
meldung von radio eriwan denn in der tat
könnte das was wir gerade erleben der
entscheidende moment sein um nach
lösungen zu suchen und hier liebe visual
politik fans wird's erst so richtig
interessant denn nun gehen wir zu der
großen und weltbewegende frage über
welchen weg kann spanien einschlagen um
diesen wirtschaftlich sozialen tsunami
zu entkommen der das land bedroht also
schnallt euch an
segeln in stürmischen gewässern
machen wir uns nichts vor es gibt sehr
viele dinge die spanien anpacken was
wenn es nicht unter der last der
wirtschaftlichen unzulänglichkeit
zusammen brechen will wenn es also immer
weniger menschen im erwerbsfähigen alter
und eine viel größere bevölkerung über
65 gibt wäre die erste maßnahme die
arbeitnehmer dazu zu bringen später in
rente zu gehen dies würde die
rentenausgaben senken und gleichzeitig
die einnahmen erhöhen
aber einen augenblick später in rente
gehen reden wir hier von menschen die
arbeiten müssen bis sie umfallen nun
offensichtlich nicht
als 1967 in spanien das
renteneintrittsalter von 65 jahren
eingeführt wurde sah vieles noch ganz
anders aus die menschen erreichten diese
altersgrenze in viel schlechtere
gesundheitliche verfassung als heute
denn seither hat sich die
lebenserwartung von menschen über 65
jahre von 12 auf 24 jahre verdoppelt
trotz allem ist die erwerbsquote im
heutigen spanien nach dem 65 ssten
lebens ja sehr viel niedriger als der
durchschnitt der europäischen union und
der oecd wenn die spanien dem niveau von
ländern wie schweden der schweiz oder
dänemark annähern würde könnte es bis
2050 mehr als 100 millionen neuer
arbeitsplätze schaffen allein dies würde
mehr als 40 prozent des erwarteten
rückgangs der bevölkerung im
erwerbsfähigen alter ausgleichen und
natürlich könnte man das ganze noch
weiter steigern die preisfrage dabei ist
natürlich wie man das anstellen soll nun
in dieser hinsicht haben wir durchaus
ein paar erprobte beispiele zur hand
nennen die spanier sind ja nicht die
einzigen die unter diesem problem leiden
länder die schweden japan und neuseeland
arbeiten schon seit jahren an diesem
thema
schweden versucht dieses problem seit
dem ende der 1990 er jahre zu lösen und
ist mittlerweile das land mit dem
höchsten durchschnittsalter für das
ausscheiden aus dem berufsleben der
gesamten europäischen union in den
letzten jahrzehnten wurde die
frühzeitige pensionierung erschwert das
system wurde so geändert dass nunmehr
arbeitsjahre erforderlich sind und es
wurde steuerliche anreize eingeführt wie
zum beispiel steuergutschriften auf die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für
unternehmen die arbeitnehmer über 65
jahre beschäftigen sowie auf die
einkommensteuer ältere arbeitnehmer ein
weiteres gutes beispiel lässt sich in
einem sehr weit entfernten land wenden
das jedoch auf die gleiche demografische
problematik gestoßen ist von welchem
land hier die rede ist neuseeland damit
ihr eine vorstellung davon bekommt was
dort abgeht in diesen ozeanischen
industrieland arbeiten 20 prozent der
über 65-jährigen einfach weiter während
es in spanien nur fünf prozent sind und
sie tun dies mit einer hohen
lebensqualität und aus eigener
entscheidung denn auch in neuseeland hat
man ab dem 65 lebensjahr ganz normal
anspruch auf eine staatliche rente ganz
egal ob man weiter arbeitet oder nicht
und trotzdem gehört neuseeland zu jenen
ländern in denen die erwerbsbeteiligung
der über 65-jährigen weiterhin am
stärksten wächst denn abgesehen vom
vorteil die volle staatliche rente
uneingeschränkt und in kombination mit
dem lohn oder den berufs einkommen
beziehen zu können gibt es noch weitere
wichtige anreize
[Musik]
eine dieser maßnahmen betrifft das
schulungssystem für arbeitnehmer 50
prozent der arbeitnehmer und arbeitslose
über 50 jahre erhalten eine berufliche
weiterbildung um ihre qualifikation auf
vordermann zu bringen und gegebenenfalls
zu schulen so dass sie die realen
bedürfnisse des arbeitsmarktes erfüllen
können wir haben es mit einem der
höchsten beschäftigungsniveau oster welt
zu tun welches den arbeitnehmern
ermöglicht das alter von 65 jahren mit
einer ausgezeichneten qualifikation zu
erreichen um weiterhin hoch produktiv zu
bleiben und ein höheres gehaltsniveau
gegenüber jungen arbeitnehmern
wirtschaftlich zu rechtfertigen
die regierung fördert diese
weiterbildungen mit zum beziehungen und
teilhabe finanzierung sie sehen darin
eine art echter investition denn bessere
arbeitnehmer bedeuten gleichzeitig mehr
steuereinnahmen
jeder dollar der in
qualifikationsmaßnahmen stadt in der
rentenzuschüsse gesteckt wird lohnt sich
gleich mehrfach zum einen zu den staat
und den steuerzahler dann für die jungen
arbeitnehmer deren belastung sinkt und
natürlich auch für die älteren und ja
wir sprechen hier von einer sehr
spezialisierten und hochwertigen
ausbildung keine standard kurse es gibt
in neuseeland einem sehr
wettbewerbsintensiven markt von
öffentlichen und privaten
ausbildungszentren und dass es längst
nicht alles dank der vertragsfreiheit
für die über 65-jährigen können
unternehmen und arbeitnehmer sehr
flexible arbeitsmodelle aushandeln die
den jeweiligen umständen angepasst sind
gleichzeitig wurde es ende der 90er
jahre unternehmen verboten arbeitnehmer
aufgrund ihres alters zu diskriminieren
oder sie zu zwingen in den ruhestand so
geht das ist genau das gegenteil von dem
was viele tarifverträge in spanien
bewirken denn dort sind die tarife hat
nun weitgehend gewerkschaftlich geregelt
[Musik]
aber das ist nicht das einzige was getan
werden kann um mehr menschen über 65
dazu zu bringen weiter produktiv und
unabhängig zu sein weitere möglichkeiten
wären die förderung von sparanlagen
welche die gesetzliche rente ergänzt
begünstigung der qualifizierten
zuwanderung und auch der einsatz der
sogenannten silver economy
[Musik]
spanien hat ja ein großartiges klima
schöne strände und praktisch alles was
ruheständler brauchen und wollen das
bedeutet dass sich das iberische land
zum beispiel auf eine wirtschaft zu
bewegen könnte die sich die fahrräder
als altersresidenz für rentner
ausrichtet warum nicht millionen von
rentnern aus dem übrigen europa anziehen
und damit geld verdienen nun genau darum
geht es in der steller economy sich zu
spezialisieren und eine herausforderung
geht eine neue perspektive zu verwandeln
aber sind all diese maßnahmen eine
garantie dafür dass der feststehende
demographischen niedergang nicht auch
noch den wirtschaftlichen abstieg
nationen und des kontinents zur folge
haben wird nein ganz gewiss nicht aber
sie zeigen uns dass es viele dinge gibt
um ihn abzustechen und mit sehr viel
kreativität innovation und mut zur
veränderung eventuell vollständig zu
kompensieren und auch wenn dies eine
äußerst gewagte wette bleibt wenn sie es
nicht versuchen und uns nicht auf rasen
ist das schicksal unserer zivilisation
besiegelt dann übernehmen halt andere
jüngere und demografisch agilere
kulturen das ist nun mal der natürliche
lauf der dinge und schon hundertfach im
laufe der geschichte passiert
schließlich besteht ganz objektiv für
alle die dringende notwendigkeit die
qualifikation erwerbsbeteiligung und
speziell in spanien die
beschäftigungsquote der bevölkerung in
gesundheitlich berufs wegen alter und
insbesondere der jüngeren arbeitnehmer
zu erhöhen dies ist ein schlüsselthema
über das wir bereits in einem unserer
letzten videos gesprochen haben in der
beschreibung oder diesem video verlinken
werde und ich verspreche euch dass wir
es auch noch in einem weiteren
zukünftigen video vertiefen und auf
andere länder übertragen vergesst also
bitte nicht unsere kanal zu abonnieren
und auch das glöckchen zu aktivieren um
keines unserer informativen videos mehr
zu verpassen wollte sagt uns bei dieser
gelegenheit doch gleich worauf wir uns
dabei konzentrieren sollen und welche
länder als positiv oder als
negativbeispiele einfallen außerdem wie
soll sie spanien eurer meinung nach mit
seinen bevorstehenden herausforderungen
umgehen wird es dem land gelingen diese
zu überwinden und wie sieht es in eurem
land aus wie immer sind wir auf eure
meinung in den kommentaren schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat was ja geht uns bitte
einen teil des mit euren folgen und
vergesst bitte auch nicht eine kleine
spende über den link in der beschreibung
unten was gut und bis bald
[Musik]